and finally new rule we can all stop
asking the question why isn't our
government functioning why because truth
is dead and the internet killed it now
remember back in the early 90s when we
read about this new thing called the
Internet that could put the totality of
world knowledge right at our fingertips
and then someone discovered it could
deliver free porn and we quickly had
something else at our fingertips but
but bare breasts on the net are not the
problem at least some of those are real
the problem is that somewhere along the
line the information superhighway
became [ __ ] Boulevard and truth was
roadkill now of course the world has
always had a lot of gullible people who
will buy anything
have you been to Salt Lake City but at
least Americans used to get their news
from actual news organizations now they
get it from chain emails and chat rooms
and Facebook posts written by lunatics
and sadists before the internet you only
had to put up with your right-wing uncle
on Thanksgiving now he's forwarding you
proof 24/7 that Hillary led the Benghazi
attacks and Obama was Bill Cosby's
pharmacist
the street corner nuts with the sandwich
board used to be laughed at
now he's linked to and that's what so
great about Facebook you're not telling
lies you're just sharing them in anyway
wise are the new truth yes more than
ever people today are living an entirely
fact-free lifestyle which is great news
for the Republican candidates because
when they are confronted on their lies
now they just say oh I see what you're
doing by fact-checking me I just don't
care because my fans don't care a couple
of years ago we did a piece here where I
introduced the term zombie lies which
are Republican talking points that
cannot be killed
despite being disproven time and time
again things like voter fraud being
rampant or tax cuts paying for
themselves or Lindsey Graham just hasn't
met the right girl
but in a very short time Republicans
have gone beyond even the zombie lie to
just making [ __ ] up Ted Cruz says the
federal government is going after school
districts trying to force them to let
boys shower with little girls Carly
Fiorina is one of a new breed of
politicians who claim to see things that
aren't there
she said she watched a Planned
Parenthood video of quote a fully formed
fetus on the table its heart beating its
leg kicking
well someone says we have to keep it
alive to harvest its brain but that
video doesn't exist unless you subscribe
to Netflix
and of course Donald Trump said he saw
thousands of American Muslims cheering
after the 9/11 attacks it never happened
but Trump doesn't deny it he owns it he
doubles down he's like Pinocchio except
when he tells a lie his balls grow
bigger so folks this is new really
listen hear me now and believe me this
is new that Liars have stopped caring if
they get caught Bill Clinton had to get
all weaselly when he got caught but in
today's world he'd just say nope I've
never even heard of a [ __ ] that woman
sucking my penis right now I was bitten
by a snake she's getting the venom I got
to admit this tactic never even occurred
to me I kind of wish it had it might it
might have been useful like in 1989 I
did a movie called cannibal women in the
avocado jungle of death
hey what's up
Hey oh my god you're marinating me
it's on film I can't deny it but if I
was a Republican you could show it on a
loop and I would just say I don't know
what you're talking about I
I played maverick in Top Gun hashtag all
lies matter